tuesday morning in steglitz and for
larissa and her children it's time for
breakfast as ukrainian refugees they're
currently living with a host family the
transition from war zone to berlin
suburb was initially hard but already
her children are learning german and
larissa says she feels this country has
been very welcoming
the government has been very supportive
they've given us money health insurance
they've helped us a lot we don't feel
like refugees we have the same rights as
germans it's helped to make us feel like
we have a second home here
in the nearly two months since the war
began many millions of people have fled
ukraine
fewer than one in ten of them has come
to germany
making the sort of journey that millions
of other refugees made in the last
decade
when the people getting off trains in
the big cities were mostly syrian
although the then german government said
it could cope with their arrival there
were many problems
once they arrived the first thing was
that they had to stay in mass
accommodation for the reception and the
reception center and that could last
months sometimes years before they found
their own housing so that was a huge
challenge and the second is when they
come with a family kids they have to go
to school so integrating them into
school learning the language
learning the normal way of the school
system although the situation for
refugees here is better now that
experience has etched itself onto the
collective memory and forced politicians
to change policy
the new government has offered support
on a large scale to the federal states
this has allowed us to give refugees
better opportunities for integration
this is a clear message we're doing it
better we're doing it differently and
we've learned from the mistakes of the
past
there is another important difference
between then and now
ukrainians have the right to visa-free
travel across much of the eu
syrians do not
which helps to explain why most of the
ukrainian refugees in europe have not
come to germany whereas most of the
syrians did so when ministers say that
they are dealing with the problems now
better
that might in part be because the need
for resources is being tested far less
than it was back then
dominic kane al jazeera berlin